she wants to know what was her
inspiration to create the Dothraki well
the Dothraki I take many things from
history so the Deaf Rock I were a
combination of a number of influences
from the the horse tribes of the
Eurasian steps certainly there's a lot
of the Mongols in them but they're not
purely the Mongols I added there's also
material about the Huns
there's some some material there that I
took from Amerindian tribes such as the
the Sioux and the Cheyenne the horse
tribes of the great American prairies
and there's a certain amount that's pure
fantasy you know where you have a little
fun you mix all this stuff together you
come up with your thing and then you add
a few fantasy twists on it because this
is after all a fantasy series okay if
your wife asked you to bring back to
life one of your characters your wife
would you do it any clues of who may not
be well I don't know if I'd bring anyone
back I know she she she does have a
favorite character and she has
threatened to leave me if I kill that
character so I do have to be very
careful about that tell you what okay so
the lip mask is I'm sorry when you first
started fighting A Song of Ice and Fire
20 years ago what kind of audience were
you addressing today who are you writing
for I'm writing for me the fact that you
guys like the story is great and I'm
very very pleased by that but I think
ultimately you have to write through
yourself you can't try to please other
people you write the truth as as you do
it you write the kind of stories that
you want to read you know books like a
song of ice and fire were the kind of
books I crave when I opened a fantasy
book so you write to please yourself you
follow your own your own muse your own
vision of what truth is and what
literature is and what a good story is
and and then you hope that when you send
that out into the world that there are
some other people who will like it too
and fortunately in my case there seem to
be so Sabrina Thoris would like to know
when did you first write your first book
when did I first write my first book yes
oh god I was probably about nine years
old I wouldn't call it a book it was
like a werewolf story that I wrote wrote
out longhand and I sold it to other kids
in the project for a nickel
and I had to read it to them too but you
know it was a good way to make a nickel
I'll do one of your little friends
Madhuri came to your mater right yes of
that Korea was it was my stories were
giving a kid nightmares so his mother
complained to my mother stopped me
writing those monster stories okay
and Sandman Romero
as a reader what characters have
captivated you the most no I like all my
characters you know it's like asking a
mother who's your favorite child you
have to love them all I even love
the bad guys I mean people like like
fian who is you know the hounds even
that little [ __ ] Joffrey you know they
write about them long enough and you try
to understand them or what motivates
them and put them to your things and you
you can't help develop a certain
affection which I loaded magna which are
the biggest challenges you have faced
throughout your writing career you know
the the biggest challenges I have faced
in in my career well there's there's
there's really two challenges one is the
endless challenge of trying to do the
work as well as you can you know you you
you're right and you look at the work
the next day and it's so brilliant in
your head and then you look at what's on
the paper and it's not brilliant enough
and you know you're disappointed you
struggle with some more it's always how
do you find the right words how do you
get that the scenes and the characters
and the things in your head down on
paper and that's the writers endless
task and I don't think it can ever be
accomplished I mean when I reread my old
work sometimes I'm pleased with it but a
lot of times I kind of win say oh I
could have done that better and by old
work yes the things I wrote 30 years ago
but also sometimes the thing I wrote
last Tuesday that's one challenge it's
the challenge of doing your art as well
as you can do it the other challenge is
a much more practical one that also a
lot of writers face and it's the endless
the endless struggle between art and
commerce I mean like everybody else I've
I've got bills to pay you know I'm
obviously doing very well now that it
hasn't always been true in my life my
career has crashed and burned at least
twice where I thought I was done this
writer that I couldn't sell anymore
I was looking at other careers how do I
pay my mortgage at one point I almost
lost my house because there was no money
coming in you know I writing sometimes
at things and people approach me at
events like this and say that they want
to be writers and what I always tell
them is you know if you if you have to
write write as the stories are in you
get it down but you have to realize that
you are entering a profession where
there is no security you have to be a
bit of a gambler if you want to be a
writer you can roll the dice and and you
can you know win the lottery like I have
or a few other people have most people
don't most people crap out or they win
for a while and then they lose it's a
it's it's a profession it's a career
it's a life that has highs and also has
lows also has you know moments where you
wonder whether anyone who ever
appreciate the things you're doing and
you know that can be that can be
difficult but it's not for everybody you
really do have to be a bit of a gambler
to embark on a writer and I've dealt
with that for you know certain certain
parts of my life definitely and it
shaped me